Last week I made over $4,000 trading
just 60 minutes each morning while live
streaming the entire thing for free on
YouTube in front of over 3,000 people.
But I didn't start risking thousands per
trade. I originally built this strategy
risking around $50 per trade. And what
most people don't realize is you can
start trading as little as $4. Learn the
strategy with tiny risk, build
consistency, and then slowly scale it
step by step over time. The strategy is
super simple. The time commitment is
small enough that it works even if you
have a full-time job because I only
trade about 60 minutes each morning.
Some days I'm even done faster than
that. So in this video, I'm going to
walk you through exactly how I would
start day trading if my goal was to make
$250 [music]
a day on average. And what the actual
growth path looks like
>> [music]
>> from starting small all the way to
scaling bigger and bigger over time.
We're going to go over the four major
steps to this process. What I would
trade, what my actual trading [music]
plan and schedule would look like, how I
would start with just $4, and then how
I'd slowly scale the account over time
because when you first start out
trading, it's not about making money.
It's about practicing your strategy,
building consistency, building
confidence, and learning how to execute
it properly. Then over time, you can
scale into something much bigger like
where I am now. I can make over [music]
$5,000 in one day. So first, what would
I actually start trading if I wanted to
start all the way over again. So to cut
to the chase, I would not [music] trade
stocks. I would not trade options. I
would not trade forex or I would not
trade crypto. There's a number of
reasons why. Each one of them have
different complications. What I would
actually focus on and what I trade now
and what I've scaled with, is called
futures. Might sound like something kind
of crazy if [music] you haven't heard of
them before, but it in the reality is
you are basically trading something that
is has the simplicity of trading stocks,
where if you buy and it goes up, you
make money. But, it has the leverage
[music] that options allow you. You can
basically start extremely small and get
a big [music] amount of dollar movement.
Whereas with stocks, a lot of the times
you need a lot of capital to be able to
make something like $250 [music]
a day. If you capture a 1% move in a
stock, that's going to take 10 to 20,000
dollars worth of cash in your account to
get 100 to 200 dollars worth of movement
from that. Whereas with futures, to get
100 dollars worth of movement, you
really only need something like 50 to
100 dollars in your account. [music]
And so, the ability to start really
small is extremely powerful. And as a
beginning trader, you want to be able to
start small. You don't want to be able
to have to risk a ton of money right
away, because in the beginning, you need
to be focused on [music] practicing,
learning how to trade effectively, and
then scale and focus on the money later
once you have figured [music] out the
process and your strategy. And also,
when it comes to futures, they are the
biggest markets [music]
out there. It might sound like a funny
name, but what I actually trade is the
S&P 500 futures and the Nasdaq index
futures. You can also trade oil futures,
gold futures. There's [music] even
crypto futures, but essentially, you're
trading the most liquid assets in the
world, which allows you to [music] scale
really easily. They're very well
regulated, and so you can trade on safe
brokerage platforms, so you're not
accidentally putting your money in
[music] a place that's kind of shady.
So, what you have to have is a strategy,
something you are consistently focused
on executing every single day. The thing
that changed me from being consistently
losing money to being consistently
profitable was not showing up to the
market trying to react to how it was
moving that [music] specific day, but
instead having a plan of what I wanted
to see the market do that day if I was
going to make a trade. Essentially, the
market had to fit me versus me trying to
fit [music] the market because if you do
that, you end up chasing the market
constantly, being reactionary, and
you're not consistently executing an
edge [music] in the market. And
everything about being consistently
profitable as a trader is consistently
executing an edge you have over time.
So, let me walk you through my strategy
and then we'll jump into how to get
[music] started trading and scale your
account over time. So, every morning I
open up my charts to the S&P 500
futures. First thing I'm looking for
isn't entries, it's [music] location. I
go to the 15-minute chart and mark out
key areas of support
>> [music]
>> and resistance. These are the zones
where the market has reacted before,
where buyers [music] and sellers have
stepped in, and where price is most
likely to reverse again. This gives me
the big picture bias, and once I map
that out, I actually drop down to a
1-minute chart. And this is where most
traders
>> [music]
>> actually go wrong, where I went wrong.
They start scheming for everything,
[music]
every potential reversal, every
continuation, every breakout. They try
and react and chase [music] to what the
market's doing that day. They try and
fit the market. They don't want to miss
out on any money that could be made
[music] that day. I don't do that. I
wait for four specific patterns to line
up, which together make up my five-step
entry checklist. If those criteria
aren't met, I don't [music] trade. If
the market doesn't fit the checklist, I
shut down for the day and go do
something else. That's what makes this
powerful. It removes decision fatigue.
It removes emotion and it removes that
self-sabotage [music]
that plagues every single struggling
trader. The plan is simple, it's [music]
rule-based, and it takes 30-60 minutes a
day and fits in a real life. You can go
do this with a full-time job. So, let me
walk you through a real trade I took
while I was streaming last week to
thousands of people on YouTube for free
of what I saw, why I entered, and how I
managed the trade. This is something I
execute every single [music] day and
it's exactly the same thing. So, every
single morning when I open up my stream
and I open up the charts at 9:00 a.m.
Eastern Standard [music] Time, the first
thing I do is I look at the big picture.
I look at the [music] 15-minute chart
for the S&P 500 futures and the Nasdaq,
but I'll just look at the S&P 500
futures for this example to keep it
quick for you. And I look at what is the
big trend. Right now, [music] the market
has been in a massive uptrend, but also
had sideways action. So, generally I've
been had my bias to the upside, but also
understanding that, hey, we do have
back-and-forth [music] volatility. And
so, for reversals, that's great. I can
either bet that we're going to go up and
continue with the trend or if it gets a
little overextended, I can look to bet
to [music] the downside. And so, what I
do is I draw essentially reversal zones.
I like to use boxes, not actual specific
lines. [music]
I'm not going to go into it too much
right now, but I'll leave a link up here
for a video that dives into [music]
how I draw my levels because they're
very important. That's the first part of
the checklist. And what I'm drawing off
of in this one is all-time highs that
were touched [music] and kind of did a
double top here, and then there's a
couple little pre-market overnight
touches. And technically, [music] the
market will be right here when it was
pre-market. When the market's in an
uptrend, it's kind of hard to draw
[music] specific levels. And then I'll
go to a 5-minute chart as well, and you
can kind of see this is where this level
makes a little more sense. [music] So,
my thought is, okay, well, if we come
down to here, I'll look for a couple
indicators that we might go to the
upside, and I'll buy. Or if we pop up
here, I'll look [music] for reasons to
short, and I'll bet to the downside.
Again, I'm not trying to fit what the
market does. I want it to fit me and my
strategy. And my strategy is looking for
a reversal off the lows or a reversal
off the highs. And if it sets it up,
I'll take a trade, like I did on this
specific day, or I'll just move on with
the rest [music] of my day. And so, here
to bring up a recording of this day and
walk you through this trade that [music]
did actually set up. And again, this is
something I live-streamed. I show this
for free on YouTube in real time. So, if
this is something you want to learn more
about, I highly recommend watching that.
And [music] so, first thing you can see
my in my checklist is a reversal zone.
And so, we're pretty much at this
reversal zone. [music] Now, breaking
down through that is okay. To me, that
that could be called a failed [music]
breakout, where it starts to break it
and then comes back in. But until then,
I need to see that the downtrend breaks.
A huge [music] thing is, because I'm in
a way looking for reversals, I need to
see this trend that it's in currently
right here to break, because otherwise,
you're betting against a downtrend.
[music] And it it could just bounce like
this and continue lower. And so, that's
why I want to see the trend start to
make higher highs [music] and higher
lows. That's a very basic way of
identifying a trend switch. So, from
there, the market essentially started to
make a higher high here. You can see,
[music] to me, this is showing that it
made this low right here is higher than
this one. And so, this could be, okay,
it's starting to bottom. [music]
And if it breaks above here, that would
be starting to make a new high. And so,
for me, that's confirmation [music]
that the trend could be reversing. And
so, right here I put in a buy order that
if the market [music] broke above that
high, I would jump in a trade. I jumped
in a trade, and then I looked to
>> [music]
>> capture this move to the upside. Because
the market is pretty bullish, I'm buying
off the lows. And so, from there, I
actually went half size on this because
my read in the day was a little bit back
and forth, but I still jumped in. I
followed my strategy and I used risk
management to deal with the other
signals that was telling [music] me that
things weren't as good of a trade
because you can see here the market's
very choppy, it's kind of all over the
place. And so, I had to give the trade a
pretty wide stop. It took a long time to
play out. I eventually, you know, I'm
not going to go into management too much
right now, but I eventually went into
break even, and then [music] the market
kind of moved up from there. And even
though I'm half size, the overall big
picture here was I'm looking for a
bottom, a reversal, you know, to pull
this big picture back into play. Just to
briefly show you is I was looking for it
to bounce here and then capture the
swing to the upside, right? It's just a
[music] simple reversal. But because I
used the big picture to show my levels,
and then I can find on a 1-minute chart,
[music] which is where I actually
actually trade, is I can get a very
accurate entry and capture a pretty big
move. And you can see here I'm trading
two ES contracts, S&P 500 future
contracts, and that requires $1,000
worth of margin. We'll get to that in a
second about how to get access to this
and scale your account. It basically
took me $1,000 [music]
at at minimum. You probably need a
little bit more, let's say 2,000 to be
safe. But to capture a move of
essentially $1,500 [music]
right here. And so, this actually, I
start to tighten up my stop loss here as
we start to get to the other end because
this is the all-time high, so this is a
reversal zone. I'm going to expect this
to slow down. So, I'm going to take my
profits and get out, right? And so, here
[music] I just got out here at I think
roughly about $1,500, which was two
times my risk. [music] And so, that was
a a gorgeous trade. I open my charts at
9:00 and to 11:00. This was a longer day
than normal, but [music] still big
picture at the most 2 hours in the
morning. Now, I actually have a free PDF
guide
>> [music]
>> that has this five-step entry checklist
in more detail [music] for you. There's
a link to click below where you can
download it for free. So, in terms of
creating a trading plan for you, some
key things you want to think about, and
just basing this off of what my trading
plan is and what I kind of walked you
through here, is you want to think about
your trading time frames, what charts
are you going to look at? I look at the
1-minute chart, the 5-minute chart, and
the 15-minute chart. And I'm very
diligent on what I use for [music] what.
You know, I look at the 5-minute and
15-minute for bigger picture stuff, and
then I execute [music]
on a 1-minute chart. The next thing is
how long are you going to trade each
day? I only like to trade for that
60-to-90-minute
window of technically when the market's
open. Once it passes that, I get off for
the day. And you want to have a strict
rule in place because if you trade too
long, it's very [music] likely you start
to FOMO and chase trades because
decision fatigue happens in trading. The
longer you trade, the worse your
decision-making becomes. [music] And if
you make bad decisions in trading, you
lose money. And then, create a strategy
[music] checklist kind of like mine.
Just something that you can consistently
look at that helps you be methodical
about trading. That is going to help you
be consistent over time. And then,
risk-reward. I didn't talk about this
too much in my strategy walk-through,
[music] but think about how much you're
going to target roughly every trade.
Like for me, if the market doesn't look
like it has at least two times my risk
[music] of movement in play. Like for
this trade here, I jumped in because I
saw the potential to the upside of the
market was at least two times my [music]
risk. But if it's a lot smaller, like
let's say if I jumped in here expecting
it to go up here and then reverse, the
risk reward there isn't good anymore.
And so let's jump into now how you can
start doing this with $4 [music] and
scale up from there. And so the rough
step process I think you should take
[music]
and I would take again if I started over
is demo trade. [music]
When you're first starting out you're
going to make so many mistakes and
mistakes in trading is lost money.
[music] You will lose money every time
you make a mistake trading. Sometimes
you'll get lucky and actually you could
win, but in the long run you're going to
lose money. I know you really want to
jump into making real money because
that's why we're all here, but you got
to go through it the [music] right way.
And so on NinjaTrader you can start demo
trading, which I'll leave a link for
this below, you can start demo trading
by opening an account and all it does
after the first two weeks you actually
get data for free,
>> [music]
>> but after two weeks you do have to pay
$4 a month for data. You essentially
have to get live data any trading
platform you sign up to to demo trade at
will require you to pay money to get
live data after a while, otherwise it's
going to be delayed by 20 or 30 minutes,
which is just going to suck. NinjaTrader
at $4 a month is [music] the lowest I've
seen for futures, that's why I think
it's a really good starting point, well
one of the reasons. From there practice
your strategy and then start to trade
real money. Shift to opening a tiny
account with [music] 200 to let's say
$1,000. I think you can start as small
as 200 if you really want, but 1,000 or
500 to 1,000 can give you a little more
cushion. With idea that if you're
looking to trade futures on let's say
[music] the MES, which is the micro
futures contracts, that's what you're
going to want to trade, you can let's
say I entered in here. [music] I was
looking to capture this reversal here,
this is on a 1-minute chart. I was going
to put my stop below these lows. I was
going to enter here. That risk right
there could be $20 [music] for one
contract. That is super small size to be
able to start with and based on the
market movement right now, totally
reasonable spot of where you would put
your stop and entry. [music] And then
you could capture this whole swing, take
3x
of $60. And again, you don't want to be
focusing on the money right away. But
that's a good way. So and then from
there, you just scale up how much you're
risking as you consistently find
profitability. Now, I get asked about
prop firms all the time. Should you
trade a prop firm? And I always say, no,
you should not start out trading a prop
firm because actually statistically,
it's been shown that most people just
lose money with prop firms because about
the same percentage of people that
become successful at day trading can
actually make money on trading prop
[music] firms. And the amount of money
that it costs to trade on a prop firm,
if you were consistently losing, paying
their monthly fees, it can be hundreds
of dollars a month to effectively be
demo trading. You're losing a lot of
money with the idea that they are making
you think you have the potential to make
a lot of money. Cuz how prop firms work
is they'll give you, let's say, a
$100,000 account once you pass all these
tests. But to start passing those tests,
it costs you a monthly fee. A lot of
times they have huge sales to make this
a lot less. But if you blow your
account, you have to pay a reset fee.
And just all these fees add up. And a
lot The statistics I've seen statistics
that show that to unlock something like
this and to start get a payout is it can
be like $800 in fees just to get to the
point where you can maybe start to get a
real payout. And so as beginning trader,
these are prop firms are not set up to
actually help you succeed. They're just
going to drain your bank account. So I
suggest if you really want to go that
route, do the demo trading, switch to
real money account because you can start
risking a really small amount of money,
get used to the emotions and that part
of trading because that affects your
trading, and then switch to a prop firm.
But again, only do that down the road
once you have actually shown that you
can consistently make money. Otherwise,
they're just going to cost you a lot of
money. So, when it comes to scaling,
demo trade for I would say 1 to 2
months. You need that time to get used
to things, used to the schedule, used to
your strategy, but also used to
different market cycles. Because what a
lot of beginners struggle with is
they'll have some initial success in a
week or two, think they have it, then
switch to real money, or scale up their
size, and then the market will humble
them. Because the market goes through
cycles. It has times where it's just
super bullish over a week, and then
starts [music] to chop. And so, you got
to learn how to adjust between these.
And then, once you have shown some
consistency on the demo account, then
take a stab at real money, but risk as
small as you can. What I highly suggest
is using NinjaTrader, and NinjaTrader as
your brokerage for this, because what
they have is if we look at the futures
and the margin rates, this is what's
most important for your trading and a
small account is the amount of intraday
margin required. And so, on NinjaTrader,
not all futures brokerages have this.
They will have the normal day margin for
some big brokerage platforms where one
ES contract can be 14 or 15,000, or even
7,000. This is a lot of the overnight
margin, but sometimes even if with this
is at 7,000, which would mean for the
small account version, it would be $700.
That makes it really hard for you as a
small account to scale and start with a
small size. But, on NinjaTrader, the
intraday margin that required is
required, basically the intraday is
pretty much anytime you can trade
futures. Again, my futures video that
explains a lot more in depth on how
futures work will go into this a little
bit more on detail. I highly recommend
checking that after this. But you only
need for one ES contract, you need $500.
For the micro version, you need 50. And
so that makes it super easy to trade
with a small account. And then there are
fees and stuff um commissions, because
things are so competitive across
platforms now, these are pretty
standard. Um and then exchange fees and
all this, that's the exact same on any
platform you do. And so I highly
recommend to start demo trading and
practicing this journey, go check out
NinjaTrader. It's going to be very very
helpful with executing this strategy.
I've used it for over 5 years at this
point. I find it super easy to execute
quickly. The drawing patterns and
indicators are really good on it. And
it's futures focused. It's not something
like these other platforms that kind of
trade everything. NinjaTrader is mainly
focused on futures. And if you want to
be focused on futures, I think it's good
to have a platform that is
also focused on that. I also have some
third-party indicators that I've created
specifically for NinjaTrader that make
the platform even better in my eyes.
Now, if you want to learn more about
this strategy and futures, go check out
that futures video right here. I will
walk even more into the strategy, but
also how futures work, how you can
profit from them and scale your small
trading account into a big one.